[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le site 8
lipdo 26 minutes pour tout connaître de
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines
au sommaire de ce vendredi 12 juin les
lycées professionnels ont rouvert leurs
portes le 2 juin dernier
l'enjeu est de taille pour ces élèves
qui apprennent leur futur métier avec
notamment des cours pratiques l'acte de
l'académie de versailles s'est rendu au
lycée white d'achères ils font partie
des derniers à pouvoir d confiner les
cinémas mais ça y est la date approche
et c'est le 22 juin que nous pourrons de
nouveau apprécié de septième art en
salles obscures
nous interrogerons à ce sujet le
directeur du grenier à sel de trappes
vos lieux de loisirs qui rouvre les uns
après les autres un fonds de résilience
pour aider les tpe et pme et un conseil
d'agglomération adapté aux mesures
sanitaires nous ferons le tour de
l'actualité dans votre département
premier conseil d'agglomération après le
confinement jeudi soir une séance
particulière en visioconférence pour
respecter les règles sanitaires
l'ensemble des élus de saint quentin en
yvelines ont participé notamment des
nouveaux issus du premier tour des
élections municipales à l'ordre du jour
le versement d'une prime pour les agents
de l'agglomération le vote d'un plan de
relance économique pour les entreprises
du territoire est encore l'exécution du
budget 2010 9
l'occasion de faire aussi un bilan de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et de se
projeter sur la gestion de la crise
économique
jean michel fourgous président de
l'agglomération interrogées par nicolas
landry à ça à commencer bien sûr par
sécuriser toutes les fonctions vitales
sur deux d'une agglomération c'est
l'électricité c'est c'est l'éclairage
c'est l'eau c'est les réseaux bien sûr
numérique qui ont été extrêmement
utilisé pendant toute cette vague
après c'est bien entendu nos seniors
après il ya eu à faire des masques il
faut savoir qu'il ya eu plus d'un
million de masques qui ont été
distribués à sur saint-quentin
globalement donc ça c'est assez
extraordinaire
c'est mettre la coordination cave très
bien fonctionné entre la région qui
accueille bien sûr a joué un rôle très
important entre le département
l'agglomération et les 12 maires parce
que c'est sur les deux maires qui ont
piloté toute cette opération il ya déjà
une série de mesures fortes qui ont été
prises directement par le développement
économique ici par l'ensemble de nos
partenaires
des mesures très ciblées comme encore
que celle qu'on vient de voter qui est
sûr les petites entreprises de zéro
salarié et c'est assez rare qu'elles
soient directement aidé jusqu'à 20
salariés puis après il ya les pme
et durant ce conseil communautaire une
motion visant à ne plus accorder de
garantie d'emprunt au bailleur social
valophis temps qu'il n'apportera pas de
réponse concrète aux désordres subies
par certains locataires de son parc
social a été adopté un audit global de
qualité du parc social de
l'agglomération sera également lancée hr
le lycée louise weiss a rouvert ses
portes depuis le 2 juin dernier
ce vendredi ce sont les élèves de
seconde générale et technologique qui
ont repris le chemin de l'école
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
et charline avenel étaient présents pour
l'occasion
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et mathieu de dominer c'est l'heure de
la reprise pour les seconds dans ce
lycée polyvalent d'achères après trois
mois de cours à la maison
les élèves sont de retour physiquement
dans l'établissement seront en 10 12
juin on est plus habitués à travailler
dans un endroit et scolaire parce qu'on
travaille à la maison mais après ces
coups de revoir ses camarades des
classes et de retrouver un peu une
ambiance conviviale des travail ici la
classe est divisé par quatre pour
s'adapter à la crise sanitaire
les groupes sont composés de 9 élèves au
contact ça change pas grand chose mais
en fait ce qui change pour nous les
professeurs c'est qu'on doit maintenir
un travail à distance pour toute la
partie de la classe qui n'est pas là et
en même temps faire le travail en classe
donc un petit peu plus petit peu plus de
travail par rapport à la normale autre
changement les 800 élèves de
l'établissement doivent également
pratiqué les gestes barrière dans
l'ensemble de la structure
le port du masque est désormais présent
au lycée dès qu'on rentre le gel
hydroalcoolique et l'ensemble des gestes
barrières
ce qui nous a amenés
entraîner une gestion des flux notamment
dans les couloirs et dans les salles de
classe la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles charline avenel est venu ce
jour là pour voir l'application de ces
mesures dans cet établissement les
élèves ont besoin d'abord de sociabilité
entre eux ils ont besoin de retrouver
leurs professeurs ils ont besoin de
faire le point sur leur apprentissage
ils ont besoin d conforté ils ont besoin
de préparer la rentrée
et cette reprise est absolument crucial
les élèves continueront sur ce format
jusqu'au 3 juillet au minimum date de la
fin des cours le nombre de patients
hospitalisés pour coronavirus continue
de baisser dans les yvelines
ils étaient 4 177 au décompte du jeudi
11 juin six de moins en 24 heures on
compte tout de même un décès
supplémentaires portant à 508 le nombre
total de décès liés aux coville dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois
[Musique]
le premier ministre edouard philippe
annoncé le 28 mai dernier de la
réouverture des cinémas fixée au 22 juin
dans toute la france
une nouvelle très attendue par le
secteur en communication avec new game
pineau directeur de grenier à sel à
trappes
bonjour bonjour alors merci d'être avec
nous et tout d'abord comment avez vous
vécu cette période si particulière au
grenier à sel et bien au début un peu
quand toutes les entreprises et tous
ceux qui travaillent s et on n'est pas
du tout fermé précipitamment donc un peu
comme tout le monde c'était on n'a pas
très bien compris ce qui se passait puis
ensuite on a finalement passé la plupart
du temps du confinement à anticiper des
scénarios à imaginer des hypothèses a
annulé des hypothèses a offert
retravailler l'équipe à entretenir le
matériel parce que le les projecteurs
c'est du matériel informatique numérique
donc maintenant il faut les entretenir
il faut les faire tourner régulièrement
vérifier que ça fonctionne les
connexions le matériel tout ça donc on a
vite repris le travail finalement mais
d'une manière comme dans toute la france
un très particulière et sans jamais
savoir ce qui allait se passer
'l'annonce
de la rouverture le 22 juin finalement
on ne s'y attendait pas on ne s'y
attendait pas tito on a été un peu pris
de court
je parle de toute l'industrie pas
seulement le passé dans le grenier à sel
tout autant les exploitants de cinéma
que les distributeurs puisque il dans
les discussions précédentes avec des
exploitants cinéma avec les ministères
il était question d'une réouverture de
laisser le temps aux films et aux salles
de se préparer avant la réouverture est
de laisser trois à quatre semaines donc
en fait on a été tous on avait tous
tabler sur une ouverture début juillet
je vais voir d'ailleurs vous êtes resté
sur cette ouverture au 1er juillet
justement pour pouvoir vous préparer
peut-être pour plusieurs raisons la
première déjà c'est que les films ne
sont pas prêts donc les distributeurs
ont besoin c'est de faire un petit peu
de pub autour de leur film et si un film
qui sort sans être annoncé ça va
forcément être difficile donc il ya tout
ça j'ai envie de laisser le temps on
nous avons besoin de laisser le temps au
fil d'arrivée
et aussi parce que
nos avons besoin de préparer la salle
donc ça peut être ça peut être ça peut
paraître un peu évident mais au grenier
à sel c'est une petite salle sûr je veux
dire c'est un peu un petit hall et
notamment nous travaillons beaucoup sur
la circulation des personnes pour éviter
les croisements on va voir les espaces
nécessaires etc
ça nous prend un petit peu de temps et
puis il faut rapatrier les refaire à
venir l'équipe qui est beaucoup en
télétravail etc
donc il ya toutes ces choses là qui sont
un petit peu plus longue en fait pour le
vin le lundi 22
nous ne sommes pas prêts pour mercredi
24 nous ne serons pas prêts non plus
donc nous prévoyons de rouvrir le
mercredi 1er juillet avec avec
certainement une surprise la veille
on espère faire une espèce de une avant
première on peut être une petite fête le
mardi 30 au soir
est ce que vous sentez une attente
auprès du public alors nous sommes
restés en contact avec notre public et
nous avons eu de pas mal de
deux messages de soutien il ya beaucoup
de gens qui nous qui voulait qu'on
rouvre très très très vite en fait
d'autres étaient un petit peu inquiet et
voulait attendre un petit peu là c'est
un petit peu pareil sur les histoires du
masque on a les mêmes retour de nos
spectateurs il y en a qui veulent
absolument que le masque soit
obligatoire parce qu'ils veulent pas
avoir quelqu'un son masque pas loin
d'eux d'autres se disent que rester deux
heures dans une salle où il fera
potentiellement show en plein milieu de
l'été
ça peut être gênant d'avoir d'avoir le
masque donc on a des gens qui sont prêts
à revenir
sachez que on anticipe le maximum de
choses pour la santé de tout le monde et
notamment ce qui est intéressant dans
les salles c'est que on va couper la
salle en deux on doit limiter notre job
pour cent et il y aura des places vides
entre chaque groupe de spectateurs alors
les téléspectateurs de tlm 78 t-il vous
connaissent bien vous aperçoit
régulièrement d'autres modules dans les
salles qui est devenu dans vos canapés
pendant le confinement vous parlais tout
à l'heure des films qu'ils allaient
revenir
je pense aussi aux films qui étaient
peut-être présent avant le confinement
qui auront peut-être le temps de pouvoir
être diffusé à la réouverture mais déjà
est-ce que vous avez des conseils et
nous donner pour ce 1er juillet
qu'est-ce qu'on peut aller voir
alors comme je le disais tout à l'heure
les films sont pas encore tous prévus
pas tous datés à les distributeurs sont
un petit peu frileux dons qu'ils
attendent les premiers chiffres
les premiers chiffres de fréquentation
c'est sûr que l'une france les cinémas
de france dont tous avoir une jauge
maximum de 50%
donc ça va limiter le nombre d'entrées
en plus il ya quelques spectateurs qui
vont avoir à qui on est un petit peu
réticent à revenir en public le les
films qui étaient sortis
début mars certains ont eu des
autorisations pour sortir directement en
vod
donc c'est des films qui disparaissent
des écrans de cinéma d'autres ont fait
le choix de revenir en salle par exemple
la bonne épouse de martin provost
la sirène de paris ce genre de film ils
ont attendu leur tour des salles pour
revenir ressortir il va y avoir ce genre
de film dans les salles pour l'instant
si je peux pas m'avancer parce que on
est tous en tous les jours il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui changent
c'est tenez vous au courant
quotidiennement c'est tout ce que je
peux dire parce que c'est ce que je fais
moi régulièrement tous les jours je
j'attends de voir les annonces donc on
peut renvoyer un peu les téléspectateurs
aussi sur le site internet du grenier à
sel merci galles pineau d'avoir répondu
à nos questions
je le rappelle vous êtes directeur du
grenier à sel à trappes
[Musique]
le week-end dernier marqué la
réouverture de la demeure du roi soleil
trois mois après sa fermeture à cause de
la pandémie de covit 19 pour répondre à
la crise sanitaire des mesures ont été
mises en place reportage de belhani poké
mathilde admis mme amaral dos et michaël
et demi d'euros une réouverture attendue
après 81 jours d'arrêt suite à
l'épidémie de kovy 19
les visiteurs sont de retour au château
de versailles depuis ce samedi 6 juin
dès ce premier week-end de plusieurs
milliers d'impatients déambuler dans
l'ancienne demeure du roi soleil on
piaffait d'impatience pour revenir
évidemment aujourd'hui on a fait le tour
du grand canal comme on fait quasiment
toutes les semaines
très très près groupe en était même et
on arrive m'attendais donc ça cesse et
c'est merveilleux on attendait ça avec
impatience
on vient assez régulièrement sur le sur
le château et on voulait venir justement
faire des photos et c'est extraordinaire
d'aller là je rêvais d'aller ici mais
aujourd'hui je suis là pour répondre à
la crise sanitaire des mesures ont été
prises les masques sont obligatoires à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
la jauge de visiteurs est réduite par 5
avec réservation obligatoire
aucun l'audioguide n'est distribué les
parcours ont quant à eux été raccourci
et repensé il faut s'habituer à vivre
avec des formats de visites plus petits
mais aussi peut-être plus d'une certaine
manière plus agréable pour ceux qui vont
faire les visites
je pense que cette jauge nous n'allons
pas la garder éternellement mais pour
l'instant effectivement on ouvre les
portes de versailles d'une autre façon
puisque on emprunte un vaste couloir qui
permet de de se promener à travers les
appartements royaux
les événements vont également reprendre
au château de versailles les grandes
eaux nocturnes l'un des rendez vous
phares de l'été seront organisés chaque
samedi de fin juin jusqu'au 19 septembre
l'accès à l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines sera gratuit l'été
prochain pour les habitants
agglomérations départements et régions
ont donné leur accord
il n'y aura donc plus à débourser 5
euros comme à l'accoutumée par voiture
et par entrée du 1er juillet au 31 août
prochain les explications recueillies
par grégory canal et on a eu une crise
sanitaire sans précédent et on sait
d'avancé
évidemment beaucoup de familles qui ne
pourront pas partir en vacances on a
donc besoin d'accompagner sur un plan
social et bien les loisirs la cette
période estivale la manière dont on fait
revivre aussi la solidarité entre nous
et naturellement puisque beaucoup de
familles ne pourront pas partir en
vacances donner un accès privilégié aux
villes de loisirs paraît être un
instrument tout à fait important pour la
période estivale est donc naturellement
on a discuté et j'ai fait cette
proposition pour l'île des loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines à
l'agglomération ont département à la
région
aujourd'hui ce qui est annoncé c'est
effectivement la possibilité pour tous
les saint quentinois d'avoir accès au
delà des 3 d'accès gratuit que cette
créature permanence de loisirs toutefois
il peut y avoir une réflexion au delà je
sais qu'il de loisirs même va faire ses
annonces sur les modalités pratiques
aussi de cet axe est ce qu'il faut la
carte de résident est ce qu'on peut se
présenter dès qu'un justificatif de
domicile
mardi le gouvernement présenté un plan
de relance pour faire face aux
difficultés du secteur de l'aéronautique
au total 15 milliards d'euros dette
d'investissement et de prêts garantis
par l'état pour les acteurs de cette
filière prolongement des aides création
de fonds d'investissement pour les pme
et entreprises à taille intermédiaire
eti est encore favoriser la recherche
développement orientée vers la
transition environnementale
un plan dont va bénéficier la pme su
mécatronique basée à magny les hameaux
spécialisé dans l'industrie du tournage
et fraisage s'étendent sous traitants de
safran et thales directement impactés
par la crise sanitaire son directeur a
répondu et nicolas landry la bonne chose
c'est que le chômage partiel ou
l'activité partielle sera re prolonger
maintenant quand il parle de longue
durée on ne fait pas maintenant j'ai
entendu dire que l'idée d'avoir des
milliards débloqués pour renforcer les
capitaux propres des entreprises l'as
far qui qu'ils soient un peu plus précis
l'un dans parce que moi d'après mes
sources
on avait parlé d' aerofund numéro 4 donc
c'est des fonds participatif
effectivement du bic fort qu'on appelle
airbus dassault safran et thales et qui
rentreraient dans le capital des
sociétés
maintenant faut savoir qui veut
entrée au capital ou pas quoi je trouve
que c'est un peu dangereux évidemment on
connaît pas la finalité de fois ce même
jour la vélostation de saint quentin en
yvelines organisée au matin une
distribution de kits pour rouler en
toute sécurité
c'était en gare de saint quentin en
yvelines en partenariat avec la
municipalité de montigny le bretonneux
150 distribution de ce kit comportant un
gilet jaune et un brassard pour être
bien visible sur son vélo l'occasion
aussi de sensibiliser de faire la
promotion de ce service qui a ouvert fin
2017 à proximité de la gare les propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude
on voit là en distribuant les gilets qu'
il ya un certain nombre d'usagers qui
connaissent la vélostation et pour
certains qu'ils utilisent
je discutais avec le gestionnaire delà
de la vélostation qui m'expliquait que
il ya des réparations qui se font là et
qui sont programmés jusqu'au mois d'août
donc grand succès ça répond à un vrai
besoin sur de la population donc c'est
un très très bel outil offert aux
habitants de montigné de 50 à la
vélostation se divise en 3 trois
divisions
la première consiste à louer des vélos
de vélos de ville de vélo de en location
la deuxième dont qui consiste à allouer
des places de parking sécurisé donc des
places de consignes et la troisième un
pôle réparation de vélos la région
ile-de-france et 70 collectivités
franciliennes ont lancé mercredi 10 juin
le fonds résilience une aide destinée
aux tpe et pme de moins de 20 salariés
100 millions d'euros de disponibilités
sous forme de prêt pour permettre la
reprise de l'activité économique du
territoire
les explications de nicolas d'andry
c'est une mobilisation générale de la
part des collectivités pour les
entreprises franciliennes piloté par le
conseil régional le fond résilience va
être abondée par 70 départements
intercommunalités et territoires
d'ile-de-france 100 millions d'euros
dont 25 millions d'euros de la région et
25 millions d'euros de la banque des
territoires je suis heureux et fier de
cette unanimité car réussir à réunir
l'ensemble de ses soixante dix acteurs
des territoires
je pense que c'est une première dans
l'histoire de la région et c'est un tour
de force de l'ensemble de nos équipes
qui ont travaillé d'arrache-pied pour
créer ce consensus est un dispositif qui
nous met tous d'accord en seulement
quelques semaines
ce fonds est destiné aux pme et tpe
d'ile-de-france entreprise composée de
moins de 20 salariés sous forme de prêt
à taux zéro les aides varie entre 3000
et 5000 euros avec la possibilité de
rembourser cette avance sur six ans
objectif soutenir la reprise d'activité
de ces sociétés où se font il s'adresse
à toutes les entreprises de 0 à 20
salariés qui n'ont plus ou qui n'ont pas
accès au financement bancaire donc c'est
à dire elles ont eu par exemple un refus
de prêt soit totale
donc aucun pg aucune aide soient
partiels dont parfois elles ont eu après
le bond de la région elles ont eu un pg
mais pas à hauteur de ce qu'elle
désirait ou d'autres prêts des pays
concernant les intercommunalités un euro
investi permet le financement de 4 euros
dead pour les entreprises du territoire
parmi les contributions dans les
yvelines saint quentin en yvelines va
abonder ce fonds de 500 mille euros
versailles grand parc prévoit une
enveloppe de 360 milles euros
7846 prêts garantis par l'état ont été
accordés dans le département pour un
montant total d'1 45 milliards d'euros
65% des entreprises yvelinoise ont
effectué une demande d'activité
partielle ce qui représente plus de 292
1500 salariés
enfin environ trente mille sociétés ont
bénéficié de fonds de solidarité de mars
à mai pour un montant total de 66 5
millions d'euros depuis une semaine la
bergerie nationale a rouvert ses portes
tout public
après avoir assuré une continuité des
soins pendant le confinement auprès des
animaux la bergerie attend le retour de
ces visiteurs tout a été aménagé pour
accueillir le public bien sûr mathilde
de 2 min et patrick jacques de dixmude
sur un rythme de vacances scolaires la
bergerie nationale a rouvert ses portes
tous les après midi de 14 heures à 18
heures plus d'activité dans les lieux
clos
les visiteurs sont essentiellement à
l'extérieur la réouverture donc été
conditionnés à la mise en place
effectivement d'un protocole de
réouverture
nous avons dû mettre en place les gestes
barrières sur l'exploitation mettre à
disposition des visiteurs des masques du
gel hydroalcoolique et instituer un
circuit sur l'exploitation de manière à
ce que les gens ne se croisent pas
devant le corps de ferme une terrasse a
été aménagé pour accueillir les
consommateurs du mérinos café malgré
l'aménagement d'un circuit à sens unique
pour les visiteurs
le retour est encore timide les gens
viennent vraiment par petits groupes et
on sent que c'est moins en moins
fréquenté que qu'à l'habitude mais voilà
ça reprend ça reprend tranquillement ce
qui nous permet aussi de nous de
reprendre nos marques de nous
réorganiser et on espère que l'été à
venir et les vacances vont nous apporter
une fréquentation relativement normale
en attendant le retour d'une
fréquentation normale la bergerie
nationale va accueillir le pari fermier
qui devait avoir lieu au mois de mai
pour respecter les gestes barrière
l'événement se déroulera sous forme de
drive
les gens peuvent aller sur le site du
pari fermier passé commande auprès des
producteurs qu'ils connaissent et avec
qui ils ont l'habitude de commercer et
donc réserver leurs produits et vendredi
ils pourront venir avec leur véhicule
faire ici le tour de l'exploitation
agricole est passé avec leur voiture de
stands en stands pour retirer leurs
commandes
les visiteurs pourront récupérer leur
commande auprès des 59 agriculteurs
présents de 9 heures à 18 heures le
vendredi 12 juin
jeudi de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines annoncé la
réouverture du musée de la ville prévue
pour le 17 juin
accès sécurisé et mesures sanitaires
mises en place avec toujours au
programme l'exposition le siège se
révolte qui met en avant une collection
de siège de canapés design
elle est d'ailleurs prolongée jusqu'au 9
janvier 2021
pour cet autre site il faudra patienter
jusqu'à la fin du mois
réouverture le 26 juin pour france
miniature à elancourt plus de quatre
semaines ont été nécessaires pour
remettre en état le parc après le
confinement et réorganiser des lieux en
adéquation avec les mesures
gouvernementales
l'ensemble du parcours avec les 117
monument est accessible côté attractions
seul le cirque des engins à l'expérience
fort boyard le chantier des fouilles et
t'es pas cap' restent fermés jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
tout comme le restaurant les provinces
france miniature conseille l'achat de
ces billets en ligne pour un accès
garanti
avant de conclure cette édition on
retrouve notre rubrique ça s'est passé
retour aujourd'hui sur ce mois de juin
2010 est au cours duquel la ville de
maurepas célébrer ses 50 ans d'histoire
avec l'agglomération de saint quentin en
iv
[Musique]
les norvégiens sont au rendez vous pour
fêter les 50 ans de la ville des bribes
de photographies retracent l'histoire de
maurepas sur la plage à cri bout du
chantier de la poste commencé en 1972 à
l'école de la marnière des souvenirs
rejaillissent c'est avec une pointe
d'émotion et beaucoup de fierté que le
maire rigoler de la liste il couvre
l'événement attendez que je suis mort
patients de naissance voilà j'aime ma
ville et voilà je je trouve que son
urbanisme sa conception est une très
bonne chose est une très belle réussite
et en plus de pouvoir accueillir à ce
50e anniversaire l'architecte de
maurepas le fils du promoteur sur hibou
et le sculpteur pour la première fois
réunis sont un événement comme celui là
voilà bah c'est un honneur pour moi tout
est pensé pour que chacun faisait sous
un soleil de plomb les enfants profitent
des jouets gonflables installées pour
l'occasion
pendant que les adultes eux échangent
autour des repas tout en ostalgie ça me
rappelle tous les souvenirs du début
puisque je suis là depuis 1970 69
donc j'ai vu toute l'évolution de
des différents sites qui sont indiqués
sur le sur ces photos quoi moi c'est un
peu bizarre parce que j'ai vu mon
ancienne école et
elle a beaucoup changé il y avait des
jeux que je connaissais pas des endroits
où je
et tous les jours
tout change
il faut son époque c'était comme ça la
journée prend fin et se termine sur une
dernière note de musique
un événement qui sera pour sûr un
souvenir de plus pour les morlaisiens
[Musique]
on arrive à la fin de cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et n'oubliez
pas dès lundi vous pourrez retrouver les
débat de l'entre-deux tours chaque soir
à 20 heures et lundi on commence par la
ville de plaisir
vous retrouverez également le 7-8
journal bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]